[Música]
escucho mi intuición o me dejo aconsejar
por el miedo que creen que fue lo
primero que sentí cuando recibí la
invitación para participar en esta
plática miedo pensé porque me invitan a
mí de que podría hablar que resulte
interesante por mi cabeza pasaron un
montón de cuestionamientos dudas a las
dudas parece que les ponemos un chorro
de adrenalina y nos hacen pensar y
pensar cuando tenemos miedo claro que
también me emocioné y me sentí halagada
pero ese primer miedo amenazó con opacar
el gusto que en realidad me daba tener
esta oportunidad
pero decidí bajarle el volumen al miedo
me di cuenta que me estaba sucediendo lo
que nos sucede muchos me dio miedo
disfrazado de dudas entonces me dije voy
a hablar justamente de ese tema
a muy pocos nos gusta aceptar que nos da
miedo hacer algo hay un estigma y
malentendido del miedo y desde muy
pequeños aprendemos o nos enseñan a
hacerlo a un lado para evadirlo hasta
negarlo
yo me dado cuenta que por lo menos en mi
caso entre mas pretendo negarlo más
cobra fuerza el condenado y se mete como
la humedad yo me imagino al miedo en el
cerebro como una densa capa de neblina
que lo cubre todo cualquier cosa que
desee asomarse llámese la razón la
información y sobre todo nuestra
intuición esa sabia voz interior que
todos tenemos dentro no solo las mujeres
no tiene oportunidad de ser escuchada en
medio de esta humedad trepadora del
viento pero querámoslo o no
la intuición siempre nos habla solo que
nosotros a veces no la escuchamos y que
es la intuición bueno pues la definición
dice que
es la habilidad para percibir conocer y
comprender algo de manera clara sin la
intervención de la razón pero yo pienso
que es la intuición es la mente que sabe
alguna vez leí y se me quedó muy grabado
que tenemos tres mentes se me hizo una
forma muy sencilla de explicar cómo está
formado el ser humano tenemos a la mente
que piensa que es la que alberga la
razón y nuestro ego tenemos a la mente
que siente que es la que alberga todas
nuestras emociones básicamente es el
aspecto físico de nuestro ser y tenemos
a la mente que sabe
la mente que sabe para los que somos
creyentes es la que está en comunión con
dios con la naturaleza con el ser
superior como cada quien le quiera
llamar la mente que sabe alberga la fe
pero también alberga esa herramienta
valiosísima que a veces relegamos y que
es la intuición
yo escuchando mi intuición estoy aquí el
ego me quiso decir no participes qué
pena a lo mejor haces el ridículo pero
decidí acallar lo escuchar mi voz
interior la voz que sabe más allá del
pensamiento algunas personas dicen que
es la conciencia yo pienso que es una
combinación de las dos cosas conciencia
e intuición pero esa voz interior es la
que nos dice que es mejor para cada
quien de acuerdo al momento y a la
circunstancia que cada quien está
viviendo la conciencia y la intuición
son lo más individual que existe todo el
mundo tenemos la nuestra
ninguna es igual es lo más íntimo y lo
más sabio que tenemos por eso digo que
es la mente que sabe
yo pienso en la intuición como una
brújula que independientemente de los
demás factores te va a dar siempre el
norte
y esta brújula difícilmente puede
coexistir con el miedo
pero tampoco hay que ver el miedo como
un enemigo porque siento que al verlo
como enemigo lo engrandecemos si lo
empoderamos el miedo todo el mundo en el
planeta lo sentimos las personas
valientes las personas exitosas no es
que no sientan miedo claro que lo
sienten lo que pasa es que aprenden a
reconocerlo y a medida que lo reconocen
y lo aceptan este nos deja de gritar tan
fuerte la clave está justo en
reconocerlo les puse este ejemplo muy
sencillo de como escuchando mi intuición
y bajando el volumen al miedo estoy aquí
pero les quiero compartir otros dos
ejemplos que creo que en mi vida han
sido trascendentales uno tiene que ver
con mi vida profesional y el otro tiene
que ver con mi salud empiezo por el que
tiene que ver con mi carrera
yo desde niña quería ser escritora
también quería ser cantante pero canto a
veces en el carro pero no tengo ni voz
ni talento así es que este sueño si se
quedó como imposible
pero bueno después de que se me pasó lo
de la cantada surgió en mí la vocación
por ser periodista concretamente quería
ser reportera y conductora de televisión
y muy jovencita fui tras ese sueño y lo
logré
ahora que lo analizo a la distancia sé
que lo logré en gran medida porque en
ese entonces actuaba más por intuición
aún sin saberlo pero con el sueño para
ser escritora me sucedió algo muy
distinto lo guardé por mucho tiempo
sabía que quería hacerlo algo dentro de
mí me decía que podía hacerlo
sin embargo me deje aconsejar por el
miedo por muchos años
ahora sé que sea algo que me decía que
si podía hacerlo
era mi intuición pero yo no la podía
escuchar porque el miedo abarcaba todo
me daba miedo intentarlo y darme cuenta
que en realidad no tenía talento para la
escritura me daba miedo no poder
conectar con mis palabras me daba miedo
compartir mis ideas mi intimidad mis
pensamientos
pero sobre todo me daba miedo enfrentar
el miedo que guardaba en mi memoria
porque sabía que si empezaba a escribir
y dedicarme profesionalmente a ello iba
a contar la historia de mi familia mi
historia y para ello tenía que remover
el dolor
más profundo de hechos trágicos que
sucedieron hace décadas y eso me daba
mucho miedo
y me podrán decir ahora marta le ganaste
al miedo felicidades
si en 2020 publique mi primer libro que
se titula cicatrices
me pregunto lo vencí
lo desaparece lo elimine
la respuesta es no
no le gané porque no era un concurso en
contra de él tampoco lo desaparece del
todo
la realidad es que lo reconocí y lo
acepté y a medida que lo iba
reconociendo se le iba bajando el
volumen adentro de mi ser
no se le bajaba completamente es decir
no le voy a poner minuto pero si lo
suficiente como para que yo pudiera
escuchar mi intuición esa voz que me
decía marta escribe
fue la intuición por ejemplo la que me
dijo que no debía contar esta historia
solo desde la perspectiva de la tragedia
y miren que a veces resulta tentador
porque lamentablemente sabemos que eso
es lo que más vende pero en el caso de
cicatrices mi objetivo no era vender
sino conectar inspirar de alguna forma
con la historia
fue la intuición también la que
constantemente me decía cada vez que me
sentaba frente a la computadora que
debía escribir con autenticidad sin
pensar en lo que pudiera decir mi
familia mis amigos el público en general
les confieso que muchas veces el ego
trato de desviar porque el ego es muy
chistoso siempre quiere mantener una
imagen y a mí muchas personas me
conocían por ser una mujer profesional
fuerte ecuánime equilibrada en control y
yo mientras escribía en mi libro estaba
contando los dolores más profundos de mi
corazón y de mi familia estaba quedando
como desnuda pero saben que me di cuenta
que los
momento son las partes más vulnerables
de nuestro ser es donde se encuentra la
verdadera posibilidad de crecimiento
tuve muchas dudas si no se fueron
me llevo más de tres años terminar de
escribir el libro pero la respuesta que
ha tenido hasta ahora para mí ha sido
una grata sorpresa
y digo sorpresa porque también aprendí
en el proceso hacer a un lado las
expectativas porque luego a veces esas
también nos alimentan el miedo
cuando termine de escribir cicatrices
sucedió la pandemia por eso vale más no
hacernos bolas adentro porque la vida
como quiera nos va a poner retos el
cobijo vino a cambiarlo todo y entre las
lecciones que nos ha dejado por lo menos
que a mí me ha dejado es que hay que
saber adaptarse hay que ser resilientes
esa famosa palabra que horita está de
moda que la escuchamos en todas partes y
yo creo que sí es muy importante ser
resilientes pero para ser resilientes
yo creo que necesitamos la brújula de
nuestra intuición
justo cuando estaba en el proceso de
publicación de cicatrices me enferme de
kobe
y sentí mucho miedo y yo creo que
ahorita ya se podrán imaginar lo que les
voy a decir no lo negué
lo reconocí lo acepté y en esas semanas
tan difíciles entre mi enfermedad por
kobe y la publicación de cicatrices
busqué meditación en espacios de
silencio para poder acallar mi mente y
escuchar a la mente que sabe y tomar
decisiones no solamente basadas en el
miedo ni en la razón sino también en esa
voz interior en nuestra intuición y una
vez que tomamos esas decisiones también
hay que soltarlas y confiar y la verdad
es que cuando hacemos eso suceden cosas
para maravillosas cicatrices
y ya se agotó la primera edición
sorpresivamente la verdad se ha ido
recomendando de persona a persona yo
creo que a la gente le ha gustado porque
encuentra honestidad en las palabras la
historia si es dolorosa pero hablan más
del amor que otra cosa
entonces como les decía esa fue una
maravillosa sorpresa para mí cuando la
gente se acerca y me dice marta qué
valiente
de momento me cuesta aceptar el cumplido
pero después pienso sí sí fui valiente
porque si necesite de mi valentía para
no dejarme aconsejar solo por el miedo y
constantemente me hago la pregunta del
título de esta plática de esta charla
escucho mi intuición o me dejo aconsejar
por el miedo
les decía que les iba a compartir
también un ejemplo que tiene que ver con
mi salud cuando cumplí 50 años me
diagnosticaron artritis reumatoide
bienvenidos los 50 es una enfermedad del
sistema inmune que no tiene cura el
doctor me explicó que el sistema inmune
se descompone y empieza a atacar tus
propios tejidos los confunde como si
fueran enemigos
actualmente la medicina solamente te
ofrece tratamientos para controlar la
enfermedad yo tenía un brote muy fuerte
no podía mover las manos y empecé el
tratamiento que me dijo el doctor
a mí la medicina me provocaba efectos
secundarios devastadores
pérdida de apetito de peso náuseas
pérdida de cabello en fin no sabía que
me hacía sentir peor si la medicina o la
enfermedad
y aunque estaba relativamente bien de
pronto me regreso un brote y el doctor
me dijo te voy a tener que cambiar el
medicamento o te voy a aumentar la dosis
no recuerdo lo que sí recuerdo es que
dije alto
necesito hacer una pausa necesito
escuchar mi cuerpo y mi intuición no
tome una decisión intempestivamente
busque ordenar la información que tenía
para analizar por los pros y los contras
de las dos opciones era uno seguir como
estaba con el tratamiento y enfrentar
los efectos que éste tenía en mí e ir en
contra de mi intuición y la otra opción
era buscar un camino que no se veía
tampoco fácil a través de la medicina
funcional les confieso que me dio mucho
trabajo en esa ocasión silenciar al
miedo pero fui honesta conmigo misma y
hasta con mi doctor y le dije necesito
probar otra cosa necesito escuchar mi
intuición
esa decisión la tomé en el 2020 en julio
del 2020 tengo 8 meses ya sin tomar el
medicamento y con todos los factores de
mi artritis reumatoide en remisión y ojo
no estoy diciendo que esa sea la
solución para todos los males lo que yo
les quiero compartir aquí es que en
todos los aspectos de nuestra vida y en
este caso en la salud es importante
escuchar
nuestra razón la ciencia la información
pero hay que darle un espacio también a
nuestra intuición a nuestra sabia voz
interior a la mente que sabe
y bueno ya para despedirme les voy a dar
otro ejemplo pequeño este si es más
personal y de pronto dudo de comentarlo
porque tampoco no quiero romantizar lo y
además creo que si le sucediera a alguno
de mis hijos me daría muchísimo miedo
pero bueno tengo que ser congruente
tengo más de 25 años de casada cuando
conocí al que hoy es mi esposo
algunos podrían decir que la nuestra fue
una historia de amor a primera vista y
sí creo que me enamoré muy rápido de él
y él de mí pero cuando me pidió que nos
casáramos apenas dos meses después no
fue sólo el amor el que me hizo decir
que sí
fue la intuición y doy gracias a dios de
que en esa ocasión no me deje aconsejar
por el miedo la intuición no nos
garantiza los resultados pero sí nos
garantiza que pase lo que pase sabremos
con certeza que la decisión tomada fue
enteramente nuestra muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]